TOP STORY TONIGHT, THE MILITARY
MAY SOON BE CELEBRATING A FIRST
THAT'S ALMOST AS EXCITING FOR
GAY AMERICANS AS THIS WEEK'S
ROLLOUT OF RAINBOW DORITOS IN
SUPPORT OF LGBT CAUSES.
>> THE U.S. ARMY IS POISED TO
HAVE ITS FIRST OPENLY GAY
CIVILIAN LEADER.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS NOMINATED
LONGTIME PENTAGON OFFICIAL ERIC
FANNING TO BE THE NEXT ARMY
SECRETARY.
FANNING, WHO FACES SENATE
CONFIRMATION, WOULD BE THE
NATION'S FIRST OPENLY GAY LEADER
OF ANY MILITARY BRANCH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: WOW.
WOW.
THIS IS AN HISTORIC MOMENT!
THIS WAS AN ARMY GUY WHO STARTED
HIS CAREER IN THE NAVY, AND SAY
WHAT YOU WANT ABOUT THE VILLAGE
PEOPLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THEY PREDICTED THIS 35 YEARS AGO
WITH THEIR PRESCIENT HIT "IN THE
NAVY," AND THEY ALSO CAME CLOSE
TO PREDICTING GAY DORITOS WITH
THEIR LESSER-KNOWN "B" SIDE
"NACHO, NACHO MAN."
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DEFENSE KNOW -- I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU REMEMBER THAT.
LESSER KNOWN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO, THIS IS REALLY GREAT NEWS,
THOUGH.
BUT SOME PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
DRAG
ERIC FANNING THROUGH THE DIRT
LIKE A SLICE OF PIZZA ON THE
BACK OF A RAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SERIOUSLY, CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT
RAT?
I'M SO EXCITED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LOOK HOW BIG THAT SLICE IS!
SORRY.
WHO'S DRAGGING FANNING THROUGH
THE DIRT?
>> MIKE HUCKABEE SLAMMING ERIC
FANNING'S NOMINATION.
IN A STATEMENT SAYING THIS, THE
PRESIDENT IS, QUOTE, MORE
INTERESTED IN APPEASING
AMERICA'S HOMOSEXUALS THAN
HONORING AMERICA'S HEROES.
[ AUDIENCE BOOs ]
>> Larry: MIKE HUCKABEE, YOU
KNOW THAT
HOMOSEXUAL AND HERO AREN'T
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE TERMS, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
LET ME -- JUST WANT TO CLEAR
THAT UP.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE TERMS.
HUMAN AND HUCKABEE.
SEE, THOSE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
THOSE DON'T --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
HUCKABEE ALSO SAID, QUOTE,
HOMOSEXUALITY IS NOT A JOB
QUALIFICATION.
OKAY.
IS THIS HATE SPEECH OR
RESUME-BUILDING TIP?
I'M CONFUSED.
AS A REMINDER TO YOU MILLENNIALS
OUT THERE TRYING TO GET A JOB,
UNDER SPECIAL SKILLS, EXCEL,
POWERPOINT, GAY STUFF -- ANY OF
THOSE SHOULD GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHAT NONGAY QUALIFICATIONS
DOES THIS HOMOSEXUAL NON-HERO
WITH HIS
GAYING-THE-WHOLE-ARMY-UP AGENDA
HAVE?
>> FANNING IS CURRENTLY THE ARMY
UNDERSECRETARY, THE NUMBER TWO
JOB, AND PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN THE NAVY AND
AIR FORCE.
>> Larry: THE GUY SEEMS PRETTY
WELL QUALIFIED.
HE'S LITERALLY NEXT IN LINE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY FOUND HIM ON
GRINDER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
RIGHT?
BUT IT OURNS OUT TO OBAMA'S NOT
JUST MAKING THE
MILITARY MORE GAYER
HE'S ALSO TRYING TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE LADY-ER.
AND NOT EVERYONE IS HAPPY ABOUT
IT.
APPARENTLY THE MARINES ARE
BATTLING GOVERNMENT LEADERS IN A
FIGHT TO KEEP WOMEN OUT OF
COMBAT ROLES.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A BACK
STORY HERE.
SO LET ME BREAK IT DOWN.
TWO YEARS AGO, OBAMA, AS PART OF
ONE OF HIS OBAMA-DON'T-CARE
PLANKS. OBAMA DOES NOT GIVE A [
BLEEP] AT THIS POINT
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOMEN IN THE MILITARY, YOU CAN
GO [ BLEEP ] YOURSELF.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE DECIDED THAT ALL
MILITARY COMBAT POSITIONS WOULD
BE OPEN TO WOMEN BY THE YEAR
2016.
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT, NOT
EVERYONE IN THE MARINE CORPS IS
PSYCHED ABOUT IT.
APPARENTLY, THEY DON'T LIKE
THEIR "OOH-RAHS" TO HAVE ANY
"HOO-HAS."
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE MARINE CORPS RECENTLY
COMMISSIONED A $36 MILLION STUDY
PITTING ALL-MALE MARINE UNITS
AGAINST COED TEAMS --
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, YOU LIKE THAT "WAR AND
PEACE"?
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALL-MALE MARINE UNITS AGAINST
COED TEAMS IN ORDER TO
TEST WOMEN'S COMBAT READINESS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY FOUND.
>> THE MEN'S TEAMS WERE FASTER,
STRONGER, MORE LETHAL THAN THE
COED TEAMS BY A WIDE MARGIN,
SCORING HIGHER ON 69% OF ALL
MEASURED TASKS.
>> Larry: HEAD RESEARCHERS WERE
REPORTEDLY STUNNED BY THE 69%
DIFFERENCE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BRO' RESEARCHERS, ON THE OTHER
HAND, HIGH-FIVED AND YELLED,
"WHOO!
69!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
"69!"
BUT THE DIFFERENCES DON'T END
THERE.
>> MEN ARE FASTER AT COMBAT
MANEUVERS INCLUDING CLEARING
WALLS AND EVACUATING CASUALTIES.
MEN OUTSHOT WOMEN ON THE M4
RIFLE WITH A HIT RATE OF 44% TO
28%.
>> Larry: I HAVE TO SAY, THE
DIFFERENCE IN GENDER AIM WAS
MOST SURPRISING TO ME
PERSONALLY, BECAUSE WHEN IT
COMES TO URINE, WOMEN'S AIM IS
VASTLY SUPERIOR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M JUST SAYING.
FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE.
I'M A LITTLE SHOCKED AT THOSE
NUMBERS.
I'M A LITTLE SHOCKED.
OKAY?
NATURALLY, THE TEST RESULTS HAVE
CAUSED LOTS OF MARINES TO BALK
AT LETTING WOMEN INTO THE COMBAT
RANKS.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THAT
THE MARINE TEST ONLY GIVES US
PART OF THE WHOLE STORY.
SECRETARY OF THE NAVY, RAY
MABUS, CALLED THE MARINE CORPS
STUDY FLAWED AND BIASED TOWARD
KEEPING WOMEN OUT OF COMBAT
ROLES.
BESIDES THAT, KILLING PEOPLE AND
RUNNING FAST AREN'T THE ONLY
IMPORTANT SKILLS FOR SOLDIERS TO
HAVE.
IF THEY WERE, AN ARMY OF OSCAR
PISTORIUS CLONES WOULD BE THE
MOST DOMINANT SUPERPOWER ON
EARTH.
[ AUDIENCE BOOs ]
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT BOO
ACTUALLY IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M NOT QUITE SURE.
AND ALSO, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTS THAT A DIFFERENT STUDY
OF THE SAME MARINES SHOWED THAT
THE FEMALE MARINES SCORED HIGHER
IN MENTAL RESILIENCE AND HAD
FEWER MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS.
THE COED UNITS ALSO OUTPERFORMED
THE ALL-MALE GROUPS IN MAKING
COMPLEX DECISIONS.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHILE MEN MIGHT
BE BETTER AT LIFTING HEAVY
[ BLEEP ] WITH THEIR ARMS, WOMEN
ARE BETTER AT DEALING WITH HEAVY
[ BLEEP ] IN THEIR BRAINS.
ND THAT'S NO EASY TASK WHEN YOU
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND THAT'S NO EASY TASK WHEN YOU
SEE AND DO THE KINDS OF THINGS
SOLDIERS SEE AND DO IN WARTIME.
I KNOW SOME MEN OUT THERE MIGHT
BE HEARING ME SAY THAT WOMEN ARE
SMARTER THAN MEN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M SAYING.
WHAT I'M SAYING AND WHAT THE
STUDIES SHOW IS THAT MEN AND
WOMEN ARE EACH BETTER AT
DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND WHEN MEN AND WOMEN PUT THEIR
THINGS TOGETHER, IT'S BETTER FOR
EVERYONE.
THAT LESSON AND OTHERS ARE ALL
WRITTEN DOWN IN MY NEW
CHILDREN'S BOOK "MEN AND WOMEN
PUTTING THEIR THINGS TOGETHER."
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ACTUALLY,
IT'S NOT SELLING THE WAY WE
HOPED IT WOULD.
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE RETHOUGHT
THAT TITLE.
THANKS FOR THE EXTRA CLAP.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE AFTER CLAP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, BEING A
MARINE REQUIRES A PERSONAL LEVEL
OF PHYSICAL FITNESS.
AND EVEN RAY MABUS, WHO RUNS THE
MARINES, BELIEVES THAT.
IF YOU SET
GENDER-NEUTRAL STANDARDS RELATED
TO THE JOB MARINES HAVE TO DO,
AND YOU ADHERE TO THEM, HE SAID.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THE
MARINES WHO MEET THOSE STANDARDS
ARE MALE OR FEMALE.
WAR IS A NASTY BUSINESS.
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO SIGN UP TO
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY AND PUT
THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE AND ARE
COMPLETELY QUALIFIED, WE SHOULD
BE SAYING THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RIGHT?
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY.
THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR OUR
FREEDOMS AND FOR OUR RIGHT TO
WATCH "PIZZA RAT."
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
IT DOESN'T TAKE BALLS TO FIGHT.
IT TAKES COURAGE.